una imagen para la historia otra más en
los primeros meses de joe biden al
frente de la casa blanca este jueves
firmó la creación del jumping un nuevo
festivo el 19 de junio que reconoce lo
que va en llamó el pecado original de
eeuu
este es un día en mi opinión de profundo
peso y profundo poder the witch
un día en el que recordamos la mancha
moral el terrible precio que la
esclavitud tomó en el país y continúa
causando lo que durante mucho tiempo he
llamado el pecado original de eeuu
sin la puesta en escena no es casual la
comunidad afroamericana del país viene
celebrando este día desde largo tiempo
la fecha conmemora el día de 1865 en que
el general unionista gordon granger
anunció en texas que la esclavitud había
sido abolida más de 250.000 personas
esclavizadas no sabían que abraham
lincoln las había declarado libres dos
años atrás para la vicepresidenta kamala
harris sería un día para aprender de la
historia del país en más chicha
debemos enseñar nuestra historia a
nuestros hijos porque es parte de
nuestra historia como nación y es parte
de la historia de estadounidenses pero
sólo 14 legisladores republicanos se
opusieron a la creación de este festivo
como spaceshiptwo disney que complace
especialmente que hayamos demostrado a
la nación que podemos unirnos demócratas
y republicanos para conmemorar este día
con el abrumador apoyo bipartidista el
congreso su poder cambios
espero que esto sea el comienzo de un
cambio en la forma en que nos tratamos
unos a otros el consenso queda también
en reconocer la importancia del
movimiento black lives matter y la
muerte de georg floyd para extender esta
festividad a nivel federal un día
histórico para una deuda histórica